ist das jetzt einfach ein winter oder
tatsächlich außergewöhnlich gebäude sind
meter hoch eingeschneit lavigne gehen ab
und der verkehr liegt teilweise lahm
viele medien berichten von einer weißen
katastrophe oder schneefälle ist das
jetzt tatsächlich der jahrhundertwinter
vor dem einige wetter experten und
expertinnen gewarnt hatten
wie bedrohlich ist die lage wirklich
steht uns allen ein mega winter bevor
das alles jetzt praktisch zum science
fiction nur hier gibt's täglich
spannende wissenschafts videos abonniert
den kanal nur dann verpasst ihr nichts
herzlich willkommen
[Musik]
anfang des jahres überschlugen sich die
meldungen ein sogenannter polarwirbel
split werde eis und schnee bringen ein
jahrhundertwinter sollte demnach im
januar 2009 10 seinen anfang nehmen doch
wie kommen experten und expertinnen auf
diese vorhersagen fest steht ein
polarwirbel split hat tatsächlich häufig
auswirkungen auf das wetter in
mitteleuropa über den polen der
antarktis und arktis herrschen
großräumige tiefdruck systeme und das
sind eben die sogenannten polarwirbel
die kaltluft zonen drehen sich der
drehrichtung der erde entgegen gesetzt
wenn dann warme luft aus dem pazifik
oder vom atlantik in die polarregionen
vordringen erwärmt sich die stratosphäre
in einer höhe von 10.000 bis 50.000
meter der polarwirbel wird dadurch
gestört und geschwächt und es kann zur
teilung in zwei wir bekommen das
passiert oft in den wintermonaten januar
oder februar doch solch ein polarwirbel
split bedeutet keinesfalls dass das
winterwetter in mitteleuropa
zwangsläufig sehr extrem sein wird denn
da spielen weitere faktoren mit hinein
fest steht jedenfalls einige regionen
deutschlands und österreich sind
ordentlich eingeschneit in einigen orten
bleiben die schulen geschlossen und der
bahn verkehr liegt lahm
einige wetterexperten und experten gehen
davon aus dass diese wetterlage noch
eine längere zeit andauern könnte der
grund der polarwirbel sei anfang januar
in zwei teile zerbrochen und vom nordpol
abgedrängt worden luftströmung in der
arktis und im nordatlantik würden
dadurch gestört die folgen kalte
luftmassen der arxes setzen sich in
bewegung und zwar richtung mitteleuropa
manche meteorologen und meteorologen
sind der ansicht dass diese
januar für eine mega kälte mit
tiefstwerten von minus 20 grad sorgen
könnte möglich seien dann auch dass dies
den winter um wochen verlängert und die
kälte noch bis in den märz andauern
könnte doch es gibt auch andere modelle
und die sagen wie so oft bei wetter
etwas völlig anderes voraus einen eher
milden winter nämlich festhalten kann
man jedenfalls eine solche wetterlage
wie derzeit gibt es nicht jedes jahr
aber so katastrophal wie sie in manchen
medien dargestellt wird ist sie auch
nicht klar es ist winter und diesmal in
österreich und bayern auch so richtig
und bei schnee und eis muss man
vorsichtig sein bei höchster
lawinenwarnstufe sollte man nicht die
pisten verlassen
doch die einheimischen bleiben gelassen
den schnee in den alpen ist wahrlich
nichts außergewöhnliches das zeigt sich
beispielsweise auch in den
österreichischen medien die von der
alarmierenden berichterstattung der
deutschen genervt sind
der salzburger tourismusverband filzmoos
schreibt am 10
erster bei facebook die tat leider wird
die aktuelle wetterlage medien sehr
übertrieben die einwohner von filzmoos
den große schneemassen gewohnt und
wissen mit der situation umzugehen
im ort droht keine lawinengefahr
betroffene straßen wurden aus
vorsichtsmaßnahmen gesperrt damit keine
personen in diese bereiche kommen bitte
lasst euch nicht durch medienberichte
verunsichern
von einer winterkatastrophe wie
beispielsweise 1978 1979 sind wir
jedenfalls noch weit entfernt das war
wirklich krass am 28.12 1978
beispielsweise zeigte das thermometer
morgens vielerorts noch um die zehn grad
plus an nachmittags stürzten die werte
dann um bis zu 30 grad celsius hinzukam
schnee und ein schwerer sturm der norden
von deutschland versank im schnee
der katastrophenalarm wurde ausgerufen
und die menschen erlebten tatsächlich
eine art jahrhundert winter also erstmal
entwarnung füße stillhalten alles ganz
entspannt das muss man übrigens auch
sein wenn man sich selbst lebendig
mumifiziert wort das geht neugier zone
erklärt es hier einfach draufklicken
also unbedingt darauf legten bis dann
bleibt dran